Oh baby the new once-upon-a-time photos
are putting the fandom into a frenzy hey
one sirs i'm leanna Galera and like you
I'm totally kind of freaking out over
those spellbinding pics of Killians hand
resting on Emma's stomach
now I've already granted your wish by
really seeing the very first sneak peek
of Jennifer Morrison's
highly anticipated reunion in episode
702 but I've got a few more magical
moments left to share I caught up with
Colin O'Donoghue just a few weeks ago
upon once is set in Vancouver and here's
what my favorite pirate had to share
about reuniting with Jennifer and
captain Swan family future now I've seen
the season 7 premiere and at the very
end we see that hook is thumbing through
the once-upon-a-time book and sees a
familiar face the lovely Emma
we know that Jennifer Morrison has come
back for episode 2 yeah what was it like
to share scenes with her again I mean it
was great it was like I mean it wasn't
that long since we've been shooting
together every day so it was very much
like like we we hadn't stopped working
together you know I mean but it's always
great to work with Jen you know we've
we've basically worked together every
single day for for the last five years
so it was it was good fun what can you
tease about hook and Emma's dynamic in
episode 702 they're very much in love at
still so that's one thing it's a good
thing it's a good thing yeah it's a good
thing at the name of your favorite
pirate drop it in the water and before
you can say yellow hope you'll find the
person you seek message in a barrel
thank you I need baby bombshells you
need to tell me about Colin you know
after you'll have to watch it and see
yeah yeah you're not gonna get it out of
me that easily
you know yeah no it's good you get to
see a different side of hook as well in
that episode in a different you know a
different version of them so it's it's
good what do you think one sirs do you
think a captain Swan baby is on the way
well Emma ever get her happily ever
after
shout out your thoughts to me on Twitter
and be sure to keep it locked to et
online for even more Once Upon a Time
secrets for season 7 bye guys
you